the movie opens up in the year 2070 a
time when Earth is in complete ruin due
to ongoing Wars with no clear origin the
surviving human population seeks refuge
in underground cities yet the planet
itself seems to be turning against them
unleashing cataclysmic disasters the
scene then shifts to our protagonist a
young and attractive man named costia
who is teaching self-defense to Children
suddenly a group of thugs appears
attacking and taking costia to a
warehouse their leader Seth accuses
costia of failing to repay a debt and
resorts to violence after a beating
costia agrees to settle the debt within
a week however Seth prepares to shoot
him but a group of soldiers with a
distinctive logo intervenes engaging in
a firefight despite the solders
intervention Seth escapes and costia
follows him through a secret exit the
soldiers recognizing costia give Chase
around the ruined City however our boy
Maneuvers through tunnels and evades
capture managing to outsmart the
pursuing soldiers meanwhile a
devastating Firestorm engulfs the town
forcing people to Flee for their lives
those fortunate enough to find shelter
survive While others unfortunate enough
to be caught in the open or reduced to
ashes by the fiery storm in the
following scene costia discovers his
unconscious friend nerd in an abandoned
bus concerned for his friend's
well-being costia revives him by placing
a filter in his mask after a few
attempts nerd wakes up and costia
advises him to leave the area costia
discloses that he is being pursued by
both the police and debt collectors
while they Converse the police arrive at
the bus prompting costia to quickly
guide nerd through a secret door before
opening it for the authorities once they
enter costia raises his hands and
willingly surrenders mentioning his
Readiness to enter the arena however
instead of cooperating the police use a
taser gun on costia and take him to
their headquarters later costia and
other participants are brought to the HQ
building where they are given bracelets
and briefed on the rules in the
background a television A's
advertisements urging young people to
sacrifice themselves in the arena to
prevent disturbances in the city and
save mankind the participants are
informed that during the battles in the
arena they must dance or face death they
must regularly check their meters and
removing the bracelet also results in
death after receiving their bracelets
the group of participants is escorted to
a separate room where they each have
personal Chambers to rest until their
scheduled battles they are explicitly
told that killing anyone outside the
arena is strictly forbidden and
violating this rule results in death
while choosing their Chambers tension
Rises when one participant mle mocks
costia nearly sparking a fight RDM
intervenes and diffuses the situation
directing them to their respective
Corners during this time costia becomes
intrigued by a beautiful girl Anna and
Chris discloses that unlike others
forced into the arena Anna joined
willingly for the cause and is out of
his League later during a group dinner
mendal attempts to flirt with Anna
prompting costia to intervene this leads
to a heated brawl between costia and
mendal zebra the group's manager
observes the commotion on a screen and
swiftly arrives to address the situation
instructing them to return to their
Chambers meanwhile nerd facing breathing
difficulties heads back to the abandoned
bus in search of filters to his dismay
upon entering the bus he discovers Seth
waiting with filters in hand wearing a
Sinister smile the next morning the
participants are aroused with an
announcement signaling the start of the
first battle for sacrifice they are
instructed to prepare for the impending
Showdown the participants are then
presented in front of the city's
residents where they are briefed by the
master raspor and they take a vow to
sacrifice themselves for the Earth
before the game surprisingly costia and
another player named Siri are chosen for
the first dance battle the scene then
shifts to the battle between costia and
Siri broadcasted live on screens
throughout the village and City the
entire Community eagerly anticipates the
dance face off believing it will appease
the Earth and halt recent eruptions
taking multiple lives soon the battle
begins and both dancers experience
unique surges of energy while their
bracelet battery bars decrease increase
with every powerful move costia
successfully dances Until the End
emerging Victorious as s's bracelet
depletes he vanishes creating the
illusion that the Earth has consumed him
as a sacrifice the DJ then collects his
bracelets and keeps it at a secret place
following the fight cosier returns to
his chamber and notices zebra entering
one as well intrigued he follows her
confessing his Crush however zebra
rejects his advances advising him to
step back to remain alive unbeknownst to
her costia skillfully engages her in the
conversation and swipes her badge before
leaving the chamber he uses the same
badge to lock her inside meanwhile the
Master of Ceremonies raspad summons his
daughter Anna for a meeting he questions
her decision to become a Challenger in
the arena without his knowing Anna
explains that she's doing it in memory
of her late best friend lra who died in
the arena due to raspor E's choice for
revenge against lra's father at this
moment Anna reveals that she is
determined to become the champion and
uncover the truth about what's happening
happening in the bunker despite Ras
porod's warning that she may get killed
the girl remains Resolute and leaves the
room meanwhile costia and RM prepare to
infiltrate the facility and Escape using
zebra's badge the former opens the
Escape door but before they can leave
security arrives and arrests them they
are then brought before the master
unexpectedly RDM betrays costia accusing
him of attempting to escape and taking
him along upon hearing this raspal
instructs costia to stay and lets RDM go
with one of his associates Ates Digi it
is revealed that Digi is against the
master and aims to eliminate him taking
over his position he also Praises RDM
for the information and assures him of
assistance during the competition
following the previous dance battle the
DJ prepares for the next sacrifice with
RDM and a girl Challenger selected in
the midst of this Anna discovers that
costia has managed to open the exit door
and seeks his help ctia taking advantage
of the moment flirts with Anna stating
he will assist her only if she kisses
him to his surprise after some
hesitation Anna agrees unbeknownst to
them raspal monitors their conversation
they discuss the Arena's sacredness but
costia holds a contrary view meanwhile
Digi meets with the anti-as poral elite
group planning to make Anna lose the
battle he assures them that he will
ensure she suffers discussing the
strategy they are planning to accuse the
master and eliminate him from his
position moving on to the battle between
Anna and a male Challenger russling The
Spectators watch attentively before the
battle commences Digi confronts Ras
poral accusing him of choosing a weak
opponent for his daughter enraged Ras
poral responds but at that moment russin
stabs Anna with a pointed weapon
collapsing on the floor consequently he
loses the battle and turns to ashes
witnessing his daughter injured Ras
poral orders the soldiers to clear the
arena and arrests zebra for not
thoroughly searching ruslin before the
fight however he is well aware that it
is Digi who manipulated russin to use
the weapon and hurt Anna shortly after
the battle cost approaches the arena and
carries the injured Anna to her chamber
during this moment he admits to stealing
the key from zebra to open the Escape
door earlier despite Anna's initial
anger she appreciates ca's honesty and
the two share a kiss later while Cosa
contemplates how to help Anna rasp Bal
visits him and hands him a master key he
advises costia to leave and take his
daughter away from the facility
unfortunately RDM overhears this and
promptly informs Digi the latter then
seizes the opportunity to devise a plan
and convinces the ma a senior priest to
join his team in the next scene costia
is seen leaving the facility with Anna
however the girl expresses a desire to
explore a secret facility to uncover the
truth behind the arena and the sacrifice
ritual despite ca's objections she
enters a container and convinces our boy
to tag along there they witness the maze
preparing to absorb the powers collected
in the bracelet when a challenger turns
to ashes when the maze is alone costia
and Anna intervene confronting him and
disturbing his power consume assing
process afraid the maze then discloses
that the Earth no longer needs energy
and the eruption ceased 20 years ago he
admits that they Ed the power of the
bracelets to extend their own lives and
their personal benefits in the room
while the maze is confessing everything
about the arena Digi enters brandishing
a gun and aiming it at costia and Anna
realizing that the maze has spilled the
truth about the arena Digi abruptly
shoots and kills him seizing the
opportunity costia and Anna Escape
breaking the Locking System to prevent
Pursuit after a while Anna suggests that
costia should leave her behind to save
himself initially hesitant costia agrees
when Anna assures him that her father
will ensure her safety outside costia
observes eruptions occurring with people
in a state of panic he heads straight to
the abandoned bus to find his friend
only to discover him lifeless in the
chair he then gets heartbroken and
returns to the arena meanwhile Anna
confronts her father about the illicit
activities criticizing him for
manipulating people's emotions rasor
unable to conceal the truth any any
longer admits that the power collected
after the Challenger sacrifice is
utilized by the Champions and counselors
to prolong their lives he confesses that
the reported eruptions are fabricated by
them Hannah furious at her father
condemns him for his actions Ras Bal
apologizes and Promises to save Anna
from the final battle following these
events the master urgently approaches
the committee urging them to remove the
injured girl from the finals he argues
that she cannot generate the required
energy for the Earth advocating for her
elimination however ever Digi intervenes
asserting that the master should not be
the one making such decisions he exposes
Ras bal's assistance to costia and Anna
in escaping the facility and accuses him
of the wise man's murder upon hearing
this Revelation the committee members
align with Digi allowing him to point a
gun at the master and shoot him
subsequently Anna is summoned for the
final dance battle at the arena against
RDM the battle begins and costia
watching on a big screen decides to turn
himself and by walking up to the
facility as the battle progresses an's
battery depletes rapidly suggesting she
may lose the finals later Digi arrives
at the arena declaring that the battle
is not yet over he introduces costia to
the audience and prompts Anna to face
him however when the DJ initiates the
music both costia and Anna refuse to
dance causing the entire system to crash
holding hands on the stage a mysterious
power manifests shutting down the DJ
system and creating a captivating
pattern around them the arena ceases
operation releasing a substantial amount
of power this unconventional conclusion
breaks the tradition sparing both
contestants from perishing in the final
scene costia and Anna are apprehended
and brought before Digi the new Master
as Digi is about to shoot them two
technicians enter requesting their
bracelets for study due to the immense
power collected in them unexpectedly at
the same time A peculiar flying Rover
appears outside the window and soldiers
burst in from the other side zebra
arrives accusing Digi of treason and
condemning him to death she also
instructs the soldiers to inject
something into costia and Anna zebra
reveals that the duo has awakened
ancient powers and encourages them to
try doing it again the movie concludes
with Anna and ctia opening their eyes in
a distant location far from the facility
waking up to a completely new world